mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
in square a b c d
draw lines b e b f and f e as shown
if the areas of the triangles are 3 4
and 5 what is the area of triangle bef
this is adapted from a tweet by the
national museum of mathematics
for a little bit more of a challenge
consider the general case where abcd is
a rectangle and the areas are x y and z
what is the area of b e f in terms of x
y and z
this comes from a tweet by mustafa kamal
inja
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we'll go ahead and tackle the general
case and we'll prove the following
formula
to do that we'll work step by step
first consider this triangle
suppose one side of the rectangle is a
and the other side of the triangle is c
because the triangle has an area of y ac
over 2 is equal to y
this means c is equal to 2 y over a
now suppose the other side of the
rectangle is b
the remaining distance on this side will
be b minus 2y over a
now consider the triangle which has an
area of x
if its other side is equal to d
we can solve that bd over 2 is equal to
x
this means d is equal to 2x over b
the other distance on this side will be
a minus 2x over b
we have the final triangle with an area
of z
so we can set that one half times each
of its legs will be equal to the area of
z
we'll then focus on this equation
first we'll multiply both sides by 2 and
then we'll distribute this binomial
now it looks pretty complicated but it's
going to simplify
the first thing we'll do is we'll
subtract 2z from both sides
we'll then factor a 2 from these 3 terms
now let's multiply both sides by the
quantity a b
on the right hand side this will vanish
because 0 times a b is equal to 0.
on the left hand side we'll distribute
it over three different terms
the first term becomes a b the quantity
squared
the second term we add a factor of a b
and the third term the denominator of a
b will vanish
this equation looks complicated but it's
actually something you should be able to
solve
this is going to be a quadratic equation
in the variable a b
so we can use the quadratic formula to
solve it a b will be equal to the
opposite of the coefficient on a b
plus or minus the following all over 2.
we then will simplify the square root by
factoring out a 2 and then these factors
of two will all cancel out
so a b will be equal to x plus y plus z
plus or minus the following square root
now it looks like we have two choices
plus or minus but here's how we can rule
out one of the choices
recall that a b is equal to the area of
the rectangle and that has to be larger
than x plus y plus z because those are
the areas of those three triangles
since a b is larger than x plus y plus z
we will need the positive square root we
don't want to subtract anything from it
the area is going to be larger than the
areas of the three triangles
so we eliminate the negative term and we
have an answer for what a b is equal to
now go back to the original diagram
the entire area of the rectangle is a b
so a b will be equal to the entire area
but it's also going to be equal to the
sum of the areas of these triangles so
it's also equal to x plus y plus z plus
w
we have two different equations for a b
therefore we must have the following two
terms are equal
this means w is equal to the square root
of the quantity x plus y plus z squared
minus 4xy
and that's going to be the formula we
use
so go back to the original problem where
we have 3 4 and 5 we can easily solve
for w by substituting in and then
simplifying w is equal to 4 times the
square root of 6 which is approximately
equal to 9.80 and that's our answer
i think it's incredible that there's
such a simple formula to solve all
problems of this type
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you